[Music]
Queen and Adam Lambert in Las Vegas
described the show because Vegas gets
crazy it's all the biggest hits you know
I've been on tour now for about six
years with these guys and it continues
to be such an honor and the audience
wants these hits that they know so well
[Music]
fans can also expect major Freddie
Mercury inspired fashion moments when
the show kicks off September 1st at the
Park Theatre Freddie was such a
fashionista and he had such a sense of
humor about what he wore yeah it was
usually pretty ridiculous and kind of
crazy and and so that is the line is is
very it's like I can't even cross the
line maybe in Vegas then maybe I'll pull
something out that's just like too far
when he's not channeling the Queen
frontman Adam is working on his own new
music it's been three years since he
released an album there's obviously a
lot of pressure on you because you are
you know you like no big deal no no and
no pressure no pressure I mean I think
everybody I think every artist any
creative person feels pressure when
they're putting their creations out
I've been purposely taking a little time
with it cuz I really wanted to hone in
on like a sound a point of view figure
out what I want to sing about and Adam
has been getting some inspiration from a
Grammy winner where has this bromance
with Sam Smith come out we've been
friends over the past couple years when
he first came out into the scene yeah it
was like exciting cuz there's not that
many of us right in the music world he's
a great guy he's super down-to-earth
really fun very talented he also told
Kelty that before his last tour with
queen he bought an Alexander McQueen red
leather trench coat got on the floor of
his closet cut the sleeves off and voila
the new costume was born
[Music]